would you rather
pick yourself every time you get up
every time you talk to a dude who's to
say these aren't already happening
um those are exhausting man because like
you ever like in bed and like you start
to get hard and you're like man I could
either I should just go to bed right now
but then he's just like anyways
um I feel like that would be like if I'd
be so exhausted and have nothing left
after today if I was hard the whole time
this pocket every two seconds guys I
gotta go to that I feel like the sixth
time I'd be like it's like an empty
shampoo bottle
I would say myself every time
I can control that I can control where
and where like
where's the bathroom where's the
bathroom oh my God not another episode
of Baywatch